ce n'est pas la pluie qui aurait arrêté
cette bande d'inconditionnels du vide et
pyjamas des everglades cela reviennent
chaque année perturber la tranquillité
du quartier avec la complicité et
l'appui des habitants des lieux qui
accueillent chaque année les fêtards
comme celle et norbert qui préparent
leur traditionnelle soupe de pied chaque
année 1 sebaï pareil là même public
ils reviennent pour la team comment ça
commence évidemment cette mise est très
vaste
elle nous sommes nous obligés de laval
ch et moi et voilà le résultat
et moi j'habitais ici et donc on à faire
dans la ville où les enfants aux dépens
dans le lotissement et puis deux puis
voilà ça fait 20 ans et l'idée c'est de
partager la ribote et vous voyez bien
que les gens nous oublions pas là sous
le banc voilà c'est comme ça cela bien
vivre ensemble
depuis les enfants ont bien grandi et
ont amené avec eux leurs amis les amis
de leurs amis
et voilà comment aujourd'hui plus d'une
centaines de carnavaliers vient d'animer
le quartier
[Musique]
là tu passes par la boîte mois
les carnavaliers qui vont encore danser
se réuniront devant chez les cabreira
avec un macadam de morue pour tenir la
distance
certains feront la fête jusqu'à la mi
journée
[Musique]